i mean we have different views sometimes
but
that's my husband you know kim
kardashian and kanye west may be headed
towards splitsville
but that didn't stop them from showering
each other with some
seriously over-the-top expensive af
christmas
gifts i mean it was just fun to go in
and vibe out just do something for my
heart
e.t has learned that not only were the
two together for the holidays
but they also went all out luxury when
it came to exchanging christmas gifts
a source tells et that kanye gave kim
five you heard me five
2021 mercedes maybach gls 600's
and the reality star bought the rapper
several pieces of art by james terrell
it's extremely important to me news of
kim and kanye spending the holidays
together
comes amid rumors the couple is calling
it quits
a separate source told et earlier this
week that kim has considered divorcing
kanye
and that they haven't made much headway
in marriage counseling
we love each other's opinions and we
definitely rely on each other for each
other's opinions
of course the two share four kids
together seven-year-old north
five-year-old saint
two-year-old chicago and one-year-old
psalm
and e.t source said for kim she just
wants to do what's best for the kids
quote if things ended she would want
them to end amicably so they can
co-parent together as best as possible
the source adds that the two have been
living separate lives for months with
kanye staying on their ranch in wyoming
so any issues they're having aren't a
surprise to kim's family or friends
kanye and kim have been trying to save
their marriage but
it's been difficult when he acts out
that's not stuff
we put on social media i'm not gonna you
know just start
tweeting what my thoughts are but yeah
we have those moments
of course all this comes after a tough
year for the couple
before kanye's controversial and
unsuccessful run for president came to
an end in november
the two were already working on mending
their relationship
following a very public fallout back in
july
when kanye revealed during a political
rally in south carolina
that he and kim talked about having an
abortion when she was pregnant with
their first child
north so even if my wife were to divorce
me
after this speech she brought north
into the world even when i didn't want
to
she stood up and she protected that
child kanye went on a subsequent twitter
rant of since deleted comments about his
wife
and her family all that led to kim
making a lengthy public statement about
her husband's mental health
and kanye was quick to issue a public
apology to her
he's just the most genuine person
and you know he might say things that
might get misinterpreted and people
don't see the context behind it
and while the two appeared to be doing
better in october during her 40th
birthday getaway on a private island
a source told et in december that they
were still struggling with some
unresolved issues